Ngoài quyết tâm dậy quyết 2 bài toàn khó là un tác xa thông và uống giễm môi trường.
Hà nội đang đẩy nhăn lộ trình hạn chế xe mai khu vực lội đồ.
Đây là một trong những dậy pháp trong tâm mà thành phố đang chín 2,
nhằm hướng tới một đủ thi văn miền và biến bứng.
Ngay mục bôn tăng bệ 5,5 hình khu trăm mề bệ,
khổ đông nhân dân thành phố hà nội đã ban hành hị quyết số khô muốn,
đặt một tiêu tự bất hạn chế và tiến tới dựng hòa đồng xe mai trên địa bàn các quận vào năm 2018.
Đây là cơ sử pháp li quân trọng cho các mức đi tiếp theo của thành phố.
Vần đây nhất tại khi học thứ 2018,
tháng 12 năm 2018, khổ đông nhân dân thành phố hà nội tức tục thông quan hị quyết
quyết quy định thực hiện vùng pháp thải thấp.
Ngị quyết này quy định gió các tiêu chi, điều kiện và lộ trình áp dục,
bao gồm cấm xe tại nằm chảy dầu điên dân.
Hà chế ua tư và xe mai không đặt trường khi thải lưu thông và vùng pháp thải thấp theo không dự hoặc hút bật của thế.
Lộ trình thị điểm vùng pháp thải thấp sẽ bắt đầu tư năm 2018,
đến 2018 tại Quận Hoàn Kiếm và Bà Đình,
sau đó 1 dụng từ năm 2018,
việc hạn chế xe mai được hiện định là cần thiết địa kiến tạo một đối thi hiện đại và có mua trường xong tốt hơn.
Để hỗ trợ người dân và dân nghiệp trong quá trình chuyển đồ,
từ nay đến 2018, thành phố Hà nội sẽ xe dự khoảng mười tướng đường sát đồ thi.